et Monsieur patron nous ne sommes pas là
que pour danser ce soir avec toi non on
a également là pour faire ton procès
Patrick moi totalement oui bien sûr mon
papa
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
monsieur Sébastien
[Rires]
vous allez tomber oui vous êtes accusés
d'avoir fait
vous êtes accusé d'avoir fait danser
chanter des milliers de personnes dans
toute la France et ailleurs d'ailleurs
occasionnant de ce fait de multiples
extinction de voix et courbatures
d'avoir créé une multitude de chansons
occasionnant une mélodie incessante dans
la tête de tout un chacun vous êtes
également accusé
d'être la cause suite à votre chanson
intitulée les sardines d'un fort taux de
remplacement de hanche dans les EHPAD
vous êtes accusés également d'exploiter
vos danseuses nous ici présente
pour soi-disant rentrer dans les frais
du coup on veut du tissu on veut du
tissu on veut du tout je crois qu'on va
arrêter
on va arrêter non parce que là regarde
tous les gens qui sont là en fait ce
soir pour Patrick c'est pour lui rendre
hommage tu vois c'est pour témoigner
sérieux tu vois pour lui vraiment
sérieux on n'est pas là pour rigoler en
fait quoi
je m'en vais à tout à l'heure patron
bon ben voilà on se retrouve tous les
deux
je vais témoigner toute seule du coup
bon mais que vous racontez du coup sur
cet homme ici présent à part qu'il n'est
autre que mon grand-père et oui voilà il
y en a qui sont moins bien aussi que
d'autres voilà c'est comme ça
non je rigole
bon alors pour vous expliquer pour tous
ceux qui n'ont pas lu ces livres pour
vous expliquer comment se fait-il je
vais vous raconter la toute petite
histoire je résume en fait il y a de sa
Fort Lointain
c'est dur de t'avoir en face je peux
t'asseoir si tu veux
il y a de sa forme lointain Patrick s'y
présent donc croisa le regard d'une
jeune demoiselle
avec un joli petit pull rose tu te
souviens
c'était ma grand-mère du coup Manu
Martine et puis tous les deux un jour
bon ben cracra boum boum voilà je sais
pas comment le dire plus clairement elle
tombait enceinte de leur premier enfant
donc ton fils Sébastien qui ne sera pas
de que mon père mais malheureusement qui
20 ans plus tard en fait décéda d'un
accident de moto
et ma mère était enceinte que de moi
donc j'aurais pas eu la chance de le
connaître
la
du coup on se retrouve voilà grand-père
petite fille sur ce plateau de télé qui
l'aurait cru hein
alors je vais en profiter ce soir je
voulais te remercier
je te remercie de m'avoir toujours
épaulé
m'avoir quitté de m'avoir instruite
alors c'est découvrir tous ces
merveilleux métiers du spectacle
car grâce à toi
j'ai enfin trouvé ma place dans ce monde
qui n'est pas du tout en raccord avec
votre ADN pas du tout
du coup merci merci d'être qui tu es un
grand-père enfin un enfant
un confident un professeur un soutien un
repère
et je tiendrai également aussi à te
remercier d'avoir toujours pris soin de
ma maman qui est très important pour moi
mais également d'une autre personne
qui
qui je pense sans elle en fait
si tu n'avais pas rencontré ton histoire
aurait été complètement différente et
cette personne ce soir on va
l'accueillir ici
alors bien sûr j'aurais aimé que cette
personne se soit mon père mais bon comme
vous l'aurez compris un petit peu
indisponible en ce moment
alors du coup pour qu'il soit quand même
présent aujourd'hui à cet instant à nos
côtés j'avais envie de réunir du coup
les deux parties de lui
alors mesdames et messieurs je fais
vraiment vous demander d'applaudir
chaleureusement ta première femme le
femme le plus rose mamie Martine c'est
elle est là
merci Martine merci
vous avez réussi à faire bouger
ah Salah
[Applaudissements]
ils ont réussi à te faire bouger tu
bouges jamais
j'ai raconté à Marie quand je t'avais vu
passer sur le trottoir avec ton pull
rose je peux pas raconter tout mais
non là ça me touche vraiment
parce que c'est c'est tellement le début
de l'histoire c'était elle a été
extraordinaire avec moi on est resté
marié combien trois ans deux ans de
trois ans
elle a elle a été mignons tous les deux
enceinte de 7 mois là donc j'avais 16
ans j'avais 16 ans elle en avait 19 et
18 oui
elle était douce elle était gentille et
on a fait ce petit garçon qui s'appelait
Sébastien après j'ai choisi de m'appeler
Sébastien par rapport à lui et puis et
puis voilà et puis il y a eu l'accident
elle s'est occupait de lui tout le temps
tu t'es tout le temps occupé de lui et
puis il y a eu l'accident hélas sous la
maman de Marie était enceinte de 2 mois
donc l'histoire est trop belle de se
retrouver sur un plateau de télé comme
ça aujourd'hui ce qu'il y a formidable
dans le moment qu'on est en train de
vivre c'est que c'est pas Patrick
Sébastien qui est là c'est Patrick
Boutot c'est Martine Payet et Marie
Bouto et ça c'est si ça peut donner
comment vous dire si ça peut donner de
l'espoir aux gens qui nous regardent et
qui ont perdu quelqu'un tous les soirs
avec Marie sur scène on fait la fête on
chante on dans e pour leur expliquer que
comme m'avait dit ma maman quand
l'accident de mon fils est arrivé c'est
pas la peine quelque chose c'est
toujours le début d'autre chose et nous
retrouver oh
c'est ça c'est Sébastien c'est le papa à
pas faire dans le mélo parce que c'est
pas mélo c'est heureux on est vivant
déjà on est tous vivants on s'aime tu
disais les bases la famille et tout
c'est important on habite plus ensemble
depuis 60 ans 50 ans ouais mais
si elle a besoin de quoi que ce soit je
suis là et puis voilà
c'est la première fois
elle a toujours été discrète elle a
jamais voulu se montrer et je vais te
dire autre chose qui va pas être je vais
toujours dit Martine quand j'ai commencé
à gagner un peu d'argent je peux t'aider
non et elle a toujours même là elle a
toujours refusé comme ça elle me dit non
non ça va j'ai pas besoin il y a nos
souvenirs ça nous suffit c'est ce que
j'appelle des femmes exceptionnelles
tu m'as eu là
on a eu la marine
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là et c'est vrai que je
suis très heureux
qu'elle accepte de faire un plateau de
télé vous pouvez vous remercier et c'est
Marie qui t'a convaincu hein
mais moi en fait de les avoir tous les
deux réunis comme ça c'est incroyable je
pouvais pas imaginer ce que ça vaut
mieux
je vais demander un truc quand même
parce que quand on s'est connu donc
j'avais 16 ans elle avait qu'est-ce qui
t'a plu en moi
non mais t'inquiète t'inquiète pas la
micro
ce qui m'a plu en premier ce sont les
yeux
le regard et puis bon c'était il était
beau
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'était c'était une autre époque c'était
les années 70 c'était c'était pas comme
aujourd'hui c'était on pourrait draguer
sans comporte plein de contre nous quoi
on a dansé le premier slow bon ben voilà
après je rentre pas dans les détails
parce que l'histoire
on on n'est pas là pour ça
il y a des trucs très très marrants avec
des trucs très très marrant et puis
notre mariage quoi j'étais quand même
savoir que là je suis à l'école je suis
au lycée à 16 ans je me marie ouais et
le matin où mon fils aîné en décembre je
me suis marié en septembre
Sébastien est né le 5 décembre
je suis allé en classe et ils m'ont dit
vous avez fait vos devoirs sinon je suis
désolé ma femme a couché Sony ben vous
viendrez en retenue dimanche pendant 4
heures j'aurais dit mais vous êtes des
j'ai envie non non c'était ça
est-ce qu'on peut prendre un tout petit
moment parce qu'on était dans les femmes
exceptionnelles pour faire revenir
Aurélie bien sûr Aurélie
tout à l'heure bonsoir tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure elle va danser avec moi
parce que je voulais dire toi tu le sais
pas Cyril quand tu disais font venir aux
racines moi il y a des gens que j'admire
ça va plaire beaucoup à Jean LaSalle
quand je disais Martine était une femme
exceptionnelle celle-là là qui est à
côté de moi cette jeune femme on fait la
liste alors elle est ça va elle est
diabétique narco narcoleptique elle a un
garçon il est là non Lolo
et cette fille qui a tout ça je ne l'ai
jamais entendu se plaindre de quoi que
ce soit et elle a la banane et le
sourire toute la journée il y a tout ça
le gamin il est formidable allez Messi
c'est un fan du PSG merci merci
Aurélie ça va être avec nous les